happening right now a tornado warning
for mesquite and the northeastern side
of clark county and a severe
thunderstorm warning as well let's get
straight over to jerry brown in the
weather center and jerry you've been
tracking this all either first of all
the tornado warning has for the mesquite
area has been rescinded but we'll talk
about that we now have flash flood
warnings over in arizona but a severe
thunderstorm warning look at this and
let me close in it does not include the
immediate las vegas valley but boulder
city in it and you can see just to the
edge of the valley until seven o'clock
these thunderstorms are packing 60 mile
an hour
winds some very heavy hail meanwhile
well let me show them to you here's the
big picture as it moves down let me
close in and let's see there's mesquite
tornado touched down about eight miles
northwest was moving south to 35 miles
an hour it very rarely do we get
anything um stronger than an f
zero or f one f zero tornado 65 to 85
mile sustained winds f1 winds possibly
up to 110 miles an hour and that will
knock you down
that probably crossed the
i-15 meanwhile more stuff coming down
from lincoln county but it looks like
it's moving to the south southeast so it
i think it's going to avoid the valley
but it's going to be a close call so
we're going to be monitoring this
throughout the broadcast and into the
evening hours sasha back to you